health services across europe are on a
war footing
taking the fight to omicron by giving
booster vaccinations to hundreds of
thousands of people a day
the variants fuelling a new wave of
infections across europe
in the french capital long queues formed
outside pharmacies and covered testing
centres in the run-up to the christmas
holidays
elsewhere french police increased their
checks on people's health passes
allowing for now at least the city's
restaurants to remain open
president emmanuel macron took to
instagram to urge people to avoid
spreading the virus
this year once again because of the
virus i ask you to have a lot of
vigilance this means continuing the
protections against the virus masks
regularly washing hands respecting
distancing ventilating rooms regularly
with fresh air isolating and testing
ourselves as soon as we have symptoms
the uk held security agencies the latest
body to crunch real-world data on the
severity of the disease concluding that
someone with omicron is as much as 70
percent less likely to be admitted to
hospital
but because the transmissibility of
omicron's very high infections could
rock it to the point large numbers may
still end up in hospital
we do know with omicron that it does
spread a lot more quickly is a lot more
infectious than delta so any advantage
gained from a reduced risk of
hospitalization needs to be set against
that and we know for example if uh if a
much smaller percentage of people are at
the risk of hospitalization if that's a
smaller percentage of a much larger
number there could be still significant
hospitalization our best way to to deal
with this the best way to protect
ourselves is through vaccinations and in
particular the booster program it is now
even more important to come forward and
to get boosted
the analysis also concluded that two
doses of a covid vaccine are not enough
to offer strong protection against
omicron
a boost is vital in reducing symptomatic
infection and serious illness
although data suggests protection starts
to wane after just 10 weeks
three jabs also don't stop people from
contracting and spreading the disease at
an alarming rate
despite no new official coveted
restrictions in england london's
christmas markets are quiet footfall is
down
hawkish british government ministers
want clear-cut evidence of a risk to the
national health service before backing
any new restrictions
evidence that may take days to become
clear in the hospital data
what happens in the british capital
where omicron cases are at their highest
will sound the alarm for the rest of the
country and given the numbers here the
rest of europe too
neave barker al jazeera london